[Applause]
what we're going to see tomorrow night
from Ohio State
for Louisville a terrific defensive team
as Clark finally shakes free with
Caitlin Clark at six feet has a 6-2
defender on or uses her quickness
slithers
here's Dan link has it stolen by Clark
Clark trying to outrage Cochrane able to
peep the pie at home
score and then out in transition this is
where Iowa really flourishes
not a stalky impressive freshman big
getting ready to check in for Iowa bar a
great feed fornock she got it
van lid can't answer rebound Marshall
13-10 Louisville lead Oh What a fine
Clark to Warnock
Clark look at a shake free Clark step
back three is good
with a smaller defender on Caitlyn Clark
look at the step back hop into it here's
Clark guarded by Robinson Clark firing
again oh my
Caitlyn Clark a showstopper
and then again a different Defender but
still
on the smaller side and able to hit it
15 points in the quarter for Clark
zings it Cross Court Catch Fire and pick
for Morton
Clark looking to shake Jones dumps it
underneath
it in possession arrow belongs to Iowa
so it's going to stay here
[Applause]
here's Clark opening the corner she got
it
and that can't happen because Caitlyn
Clark is too it is sweet 16.
here's Clark giving it up sonano able to
lay it in
meanwhile Louisville nice response here
all Clark shook free a moment or knock
able to knock down from three
look at two two players shadowing
Caitlyn Clark Warnock again
McKenna Warnock delivering
[Applause]
Clark will fire and take
we'll get back to that here Caitlin
Clark you know when she goes left watch
out that's where she is so that is just
a little more pointed and it's obviously
been effective
Clark finds Stokke who lays it in Hannah
Stokey The Freshman an impressive first
half Jones can't hit the quick jumper
not sure Jeff walls loved the shot
here's Clark all what a no look Warnock
finishes another rebound Warnock who's
having a huge game
that's not the shot
Clarks on a three timeout Louisville
in the nation in points per game as she
hits the Deep
hit the hard part
finds Marshall Catch Fire and hit
of the Junior's career here's Clark wide
open you bet
31.
strobe
you know what's coming on inbounds play
the screen and Jones gets caught up for
a second clock
knocked away Marshall Clark to the rim
right here this is Caitlin Clark all on
her own jumping out to double team she
sensed that she could get the steals
that she could create some havoc and she
did and got the layup the other way
we're getting some of those turnovers
Lisa Luder was talking about the
recapono into the game for Louisville
Clark decides to take one up
Jones just threw her hand up in the air
like what more can I do Caitlyn Clark
can control the crowd's emotions and she
can control the game
knocked away Russell loses it Clark has
it get it Marshall in for two
if you're wondering well could they have
looked at it with two minutes even on
the clock the answer is yes two minutes
and under Clark ahead to Marshall who
takes the layup off the foul